welcome to dc thursday everyone i'm pete
soderling i'm the founder of data
council and the data community fund
and as you know every other week or so
i'm your guide through the sprawling
expanding
massive
changing shifting
evolving i saw that already data
ecosystem
so
we bring you great guests who are in our
community and have contributed
significantly to
either open source projects or company
building
sometimes both
and i'm here today with neha pawar who
is from
star tree and she's a core contributor
to the apache pinot project so we'll be
talking to neha
about a variety of things
that have sort of developed in the pinot
community
over the last couple years
we had kishore the one of the other
contributors to pino
uh at our at our conference in 2019 um
which kicked off the relationship and
then we had him back on dc thursday in
2020
so excited to have neha here today
who's going to give us an update on a
lot of developments in the pinot project
since then
so i want to officially introduce neha
she's a founding engineer at startree
she's also an apache pinot pmc member
she was formerly a software engineer at
linkedin and yahoo and she has a masters
in computer science from
the university of illinois urbana
champaign where mark andreessen went so
niha you
have some great experience and great
credentials and we're excited to talk to
you and have you on the show today
thanks pete that was a great
introduction i am super excited to be
here as well i'm a big fan of the show
and super pumped to be
here as a guest today oh great thank you
for the kind words
so neha i want to start where we usually
start with folks and i want to
understand how you got into data and
what the origin story is for you
uh so for me the fascination with data
actually started in uh grad school the
data scene in my school was quite
buzzing and i always found myself
picking uh very interesting data related
problems to solve even then
be it adding some indexing in the
map-reduce job to make it faster or uh
analyzing a twitter stream in real time
to find which
venues or restaurants have some buzzing
events happening uh today
so those kind of projects and then after
grad school i had the wonderful
opportunity to work at linkedin in the
data infra org
so uh many cool data and streaming info
projects were happening in linkedin at
that time like kafka samsa goblin pino
voldemort
so i got to see the whole ecosystem
involved uh from the birth of an event
to the transformations to the storage to
the analytics the management the purging
just all of it and that basically just
got me excited and kept me in data since
then
great
and you worked with some amazing folks
um there at linkedin
with uh shashanka
um you probably worked with bg if i'm
not not mistaken
um
who else did you work with uh jay krabs
probably um during that time
uh so sri shankar definitely
not with jake reps i joined probably a
little later then just after yeah
and
that's where i met all the wonderful
folks of the pinot
founding team kishore and sean and
the same folks who i work with closely
now in star trek
great awesome
well um when you talk about the origin
of
pino at linkedin
i've heard this about this third eye
project um can you tell us about third
eye and what that project was and how it
was sort of connected to the inception
of pinot
yes uh so
when i joined linkedin i uh started
working actually on the third eye
project first
and uh third eye was this or is still uh
still very
popular in linkedin and also gaining
adoption outside now this root cause
analysis and anomaly detection tool
uh that was built on top of pino
and this helped make monitoring of
business metrics
real-time and automatic and also aided
in the investigation of anomalies that
you found in business metrics
so to give you an example uh
there were these key business metrics
that were very important to all the
execs in linkedin
and uh periodically this
report got generated like on an early
fashion and was sent to all
uh the people
and then they used to look at the
dashboards and then uh
see that oh some metric is down or some
metric is
different compared to how it was last
week
and then they used to ask questions that
hey uh why is this metric uh behaving
differently
and then there was a team of operators
and
whose job was to figure out what was
wrong with the metrics and
uh it often took them several hours
there was this time when it took them
like a couple of days to figure out like
what was wrong
uh so with third eye
this time to get from anomaly or rather
to detect anomaly and then find the root
cause was
reduced quite a lot so the anomaly
detection was automatic the
investigation was much easier
because there were these rich
visualizations like a lot of time series
and then some heat maps where you could
see
every dimension
every value within the dimension in one
view
and then you could
slice and dice into them with like super
low latency
and then
not just that this this is kind of still
a manual investigation and then
you still kind of have to figure out
what the root cause was
so for that third eye helped with uh
you could plug in more data sources for
example at linkedin we had plugged in
holiday events or
deployment events or any experiments
that are going on in linkedin so kind of
see all of them
around the timeline of the anomaly
together to help you make the best guess
of what
could be the root cause of the anomalous
behavior
and this used to happen uh super fast
on the third eye application at that
time because it was built on top of pino
and that was kind of how third eye was
born and how it helped make pinot even
faster wow
so is that is that to say that the
dashboards themselves were also
um consuming pinot data
yes yes yeah so all the data that was
being analyzed was being put into pinot
tables and then everything that was
rendered and
all the anomaly pipelines that were
running everything was
just powered by pino
so so you were probably um one of the
companies leading the charge in real
time
data consumption even from a bi
standpoint um i imagine like
lots of folks that consume bi data don't
necessarily have access to real time
fresh
data and probably their even their
management teams aren't necessarily
tooled to appreciate
how they would use real-time data at the
at the bi level
um so that sounds like it was quite a
forward-looking thing from linkedin even
in
2012 yes that's exactly right so even
for the dashboarding we we were very
spoiled and used to just having
real-time data and
low-latency queries right from
many years ago yeah got it so when it
came to um discovering the anomalous
behavior
i suppose before third eye
there could have been some question if
if some executive saw metric drop
probably the first question that sort of
came back or the engineers would ask
themselves when faced with that
predicament was
well
like obviously why did it drop but um it
could have been due to some data quality
issue and not necessarily an actual
material change in the metric itself
i i assume so that's probably one of the
early things that you
built third eye to figure out
yes so one of the things that
people had to figure out at that time
was
uh data quality definitely what ended up
happening is we had all this data in
data lake like in hadoop and then we had
to run batch jobs to figure out that
sometimes that hey we need to
find out this other metrics behavior
based on this or we need more
information so it was a very slow
process and
uh just correlating a lot of other
events
like the deployments or like
uh experiments also kind of help us
catch all these data quality issues or
find out that some pipelines have not
run so all those things
that's great so i i guess i wasn't
entirely familiar with the
complexity of that use case but it's
amazing that you could suck in signal
from
many other types of sources and actually
use it to augment your anomaly signals
in that way
um so then after that use case i think
the the other use case that cash talks
about is well pinot is used to
um show all the metrics on who's visited
your profile or how many people have
like visited you and all sort of those
internal aggregations that the linkedin
product displays to end users
that show how popular they are or or you
know or that that type of data
but that was actually a use case that
came after third eye
uh so i would say it was a
little before or kind of about the same
time okay that both of these things were
happening
and
this this is one of the very cool things
that i uh learned at linkedin or
that i saw at linkedin that
uh
everyone was always trying to stay ahead
of the game and set the trend instead of
catch the trend and then
get on it later on so
showing the profile views on
the who viewed my profile app and then
giving the users the ability to slice
and dice on it
like just opening it up to the users and
saying that hey you can go slice and
dice on it by country or
job title
this is
uh user facing analytics it was uh like
a very new category at that time and
it's still a very new unchartered
category for many companies
uh and even like a few years ago this
was like
seven or eight years ago
uh from then itself
this was being done at linkedin which
was like a really cool thing so there
was always this
uh
urge to stay ahead think ahead that hey
no internal analytics is not good enough
we need to we need real time we need
systems like pino or batch is not good
enough we need to make the anomaly
detection real time we have to get away
from just like a report being sent to
users so this was like very cool
engineering culture at linkedin
got it awesome
um and so
i think you know listeners can probably
um decode like the the gist of what
pinot is about but if you had to say it
in one sentence
how would you describe pinot
if i had to say it in one sentence it
would be
pinot is an olap data store so
specializing in analytical workloads
that gives you ultra low latency high
throughput analytics
uh which helps you enter the new breed
of real-time user-facing analytics and
lets you unlock challenging and
interesting use cases that
will help take your business to the next
level
very well said
um
and so
let's let's just do a quick refresher um
for folks who
might not be intimately familiar with
the project
um can you talk to us about the main
architectural components of the system
uh yes so from the architecture
perspective there are
just three main components
uh
the first main component is the pinot
servers so this is kind of like the
storage layer so to say
this is
these are the components that will host
the data
in the form of segments
segments are just portions of the data
packed in columnar fashion along with
indexes and dictionaries
then we have the next component on top
of the servers is the
is the query serving layer it's the
pinot brokers
these are the ones that will uh take
the queries from clients scatter them to
the servers gather the results merge
them and then send them back
and then finally we have the controllers
that are with the help of apache helix
manage the whole state of the cluster
and then any instance that comes up in
pino gets one or more of these roles so
when you're just getting started you can
just have a single instance that takes
up all these roles and then as you move
into more production settings you can
start separating the roles
and then at any of these layers you can
independently uh scale them horizontally
or vertically
uh yeah so this would be kind of a quick
summary of the architecture
got it okay makes sense
um and what about the what about the
ingest layer i guess the the
the data ingest is sort of a
a separate tool that's used to get data
into into pinot so that's not a
that's not a process
in the system or a piece of the archive
uh so yes and no that's like a really
good question
so
pinot can ingest from uh real-time
streaming systems like kafka kinesis or
pulsar pub pubsub
and that happens natively uh you don't
need any other components so the server
the pino servers
that's the layer that has the ability to
directly talk to these streaming systems
and uh
ingest data they
the servers do their own um
offset management check pointing to make
sure that our consumption is exactly
once and that
and that it's like it keeps going
continuously it's fault tolerant
but if you have data in say a data lake
somewhere and then you need to do some
batch ingestion uh periodically into
pino
in that case uh
you did need
like an external system say you had to
write
a mapreduce job or a spark job so you
had to bring up those clusters and then
periodically say create a pinot segment
and push it into the pinot cluster
but now we have a new component
not so new anymore but still sort of
unpopular yet
that i did not bring up in the
architecture it's called the pino minion
okay
and this component has been built to
offload computationally intensive tasks
from uh other components
and the second reason it was built is to
uh
help pinot take in more
uh activities that were not happening
natively and then just bring them into
pino i see
ingestion is one of those
so we have
the minions they are able to
take pinot from a push based model where
users had to kind of
generate the segments maintain those
external systems and push the segments
to pino
the minions are
allowing us to go from that to a pull
based model like in the streaming
systems
so we simply just like in streaming
ingestion simply point to
the source the data lake in this case
and
the minions are just able to ingest the
data build the segments push it into the
pinot cluster
uh keep doing this incrementally also uh
keep the source and the segments in sync
uh
so yes with this
with this it's becoming more and more
native to batch ingestion in
you know itself and okay lead the users
from all those external systems
i see
so i saw that in your product demo um
you have this notion of a data manager
and so the data manager must be
supporting or supported by both the
minions and the ingest
on the on the server side i assume it's
sort of a logical representation of
pieces of both of those things is that
right
yes that's a very accurate observation
so
data manager is actually in star tree
it's not in apache pilot i see
but the streaming ingestion and some of
the minion ingestion pieces are in open
source
in star trek we've kind of built on top
of these to add say a lot more
connectors
for example we have a snowflake
connector so if you have
data in data warehouses snowflake or
bigquery or any other sql based data
system in
open source you know you would have to
write some etl jobs to get that data
into a data lake or put it into kafka in
some form that
pino is able to natively ingest from
but we kind of added more connectors
there to just natively ingest even from
that
and then data set manager as you rightly
pointed out is uh
on top of all of this so it's just
it will let you ingest no matter where
your data is and suggestion for the user
should just be
a few clicks
uh it should just be a matter of hey
tell yours where my data is at
uh and then pino figures out the rest
get and helping us uh get
uh get past all those
external systems and writing the
pipelines and
monitoring those
and then it will be able to do it
whether it's like a streaming system or
a data warehouse or a sql based data
source or data in the data lake and so
on okay
well um since we're on the topic um i do
want to ask a question about the ingest
we can move on to talk more about the
community and some of the other things
after that but
um i did notice that in the data manager
there's this notion of
um sort of validating the input schema
but then also translating it into a
pinot schema which may be
different or you may you may make some
decisions
to optimize the data for pinot storage
um i was just curious as to
how that process works and and why that
is um can you talk about any of that
schema inference piece of it
uh yes definitely uh
so
uh so you're right when there's this uh
schema to your source data and what you
might actually want in your pinot table
uh it can be pretty different and the
motivation behind adding the schema
influence and also table config
influence
into data set manager is that
we shouldn't put the burden on the user
that hey pino needs a schema you know
needs a table config with these these
things set in there
from the user's perspective it should be
as simple as
uh here's my kafka topic or here's the
s3 bucket where i have my data and then
just like figure it out
and then we
take that
read a few like we read some sample data
and come up with hey here's what we
think your schema should be
yours what we think the indexing should
be for your uh columns
this is how we think you should uh
structure some of the unstructured or
the semi-structured or the nested fields
so that you can query them better
and then of course we give
the user an ability to step in at any
stage of that inference and say
oh here's an extra column that i want
that's maybe a derived column or maybe i
don't care about this column or
i know that my query characteristics are
going to be different for this based on
my use case so here's some extra index
that i want to add
but for the very base case uh it should
just be hey everything's figured out for
you
yeah i appreciated that in in seeing how
the star tree tool is set up that you're
really focusing on simplicity and use of
use and
you know trying to present user with
smart defaults that they could just
click through
if they wanted to but there's also some
power where they could
manipulate those configuration values
throughout the ingest process as well or
add
computed
columns
or sort of alternate um data definitions
that might be more more meaningful to
them
so i found that that to be quite
powerful
well um let's switch gears and talk a
little bit about the the pinot community
and how that's evolved because
i know you've seen a lot of growth in
the community and
um and i i feel like um as for any you
know well-run open source project
you've allowed the community to to sort
of help you determine
where to go next
um so
i kind of wanted to ask you um just at a
high level
how would you say
pinot is is different now
than what it was um in sort of its first
when when it was first envisioned at
linkedin are there other like many
significant things or a few significant
things how would you sort of describe
the difference as to where we are today
and just the state of the union with
peta pinot in general
uh so
i would say that the core components and
the core principles are still very much
the same
but on a very high level
pinot today compared to a few years ago
is just a lot more holistic and
extensible than it used to be um
so and
so this mainly happened because
while like uber and linkedin success
stories like they were awesome and the
adoption and the use cases done there
they were like really amazing but these
companies were
companies with like mature data orgs
there were teams to handle deployments
operations ingestion
there was not a lot of variability in
what was the source of your events or
where what you would use as your data
lake
but then out in the wild it was a very
different story there was like less
control more diversity in the
sources and the visualization layer and
all that
um
so that kind of
helped to drive this change from it
being uh
just integrated with a few things to now
very extensible and very easy to plug in
other things and just more uh
more open to
to more opinions
um so so the and we'll talk about this a
bit um it's the growth of that connector
ecosystem i know that uc is kind of a
sign of the
maturity of the product and
the project and the ability to embrace
different types of of data
sort of wherever it lives
on the customer side
uh yes so the connected ecosystem
the growth of that and just the number
of amazing contributions for getting to
that is definitely like a great sign
that we're seeing that
uh
the community is involved in helping us
shape
things
uh and it was uh
not just the connectors right there was
like
some more gaps that we kind of
identified and like kind of fixed that
help
just shape or and fuel the community
even more so for example um
like a couple of years ago when this is
around the time when a few of us got
together and uh at star tree we kind of
really took a deep look into the
problems that were being faced by the
community and just really thought hey
how can we help the community succeed uh
so one thing that was uh very evident at
that time was that pinot is like this
very uh good production quality system
but the
it was not very developer friendly so
the getting started experience was not
quite there so we had to make sure that
it's very easy for somebody to just come
in
uh be able to seamlessly run the quick
start and
uh just be able to get started and then
slowly slowly figure out all the amazing
configurations that are there to do more
and more
um
linkedin and uber both started off as
on-prem deployments so we had to make
sure that we make it cloud-native at
kubernetes deployment support
uh and then definitely all the
connectors so for that
we have to make sure that just because
we want to add a lot of connectors uh
doesn't mean every time you have to
go and duplicate a lot of code or
understand how the core engine is
working
so making sure that the architecture is
very pluggable and with just minimum
implementations of like a clean
interface you're able to get to a new
connector
and when we did that we got just uh
amazing contributions like the kinesis
connector the pulsar connector all from
the community
and
some very interesting integrations like
uh there's now a pin no flink sink to
just put data directly from flink into
pino
there's like this cool recipe of how to
get data from the bzm into pino
there's like more integrations on the
visualization layer so superset and
tableau
and all this
all this goodness was coming to us all
these
inputs were coming to us from the
community which was really great
that's great um and did you have a sense
that there were so many
companies out there using pinot
before this or was this sort of a aha
moment to you when you realized how
widespread the interest and adoption of
pinot potentially was or did you have
other metrics prior that showed you this
uh so i would say prior to maybe 2020 we
did not
have
any
real metrics that we were tracking to
know this we just knew that there was
linkedin uber and like a couple of other
companies
and then after that we were uh
we really started keeping a track of
this like the number of docker downloads
or uh
the activity in our slack channels and
just the participation in our meetups or
we used to do this
survey to decide what we should do in
the
next few months in pino and we also send
it to the pinot slack channel and then
we used to get amazing participation on
it on like voting on the features that
we thought
we should do or some new ideas
uh that's kind of when we started
realizing that hey
adoption is like really growing
we went from some 100 members in the
slack channel in early 2020 to
uh
almost 3 000 like
in the late 2000s of number of members
in the slack today
it's one of the most active slack
communities that i've seen
and
adoptions have been there from
very different
use cases as well now different sectors
so we have
uh fintech we have stripe and we pay we
have
target and walmart
in retail we have uh
cisco doing webex analytics we're doing
they're doing a meetup for the pinot
community next week actually okay
yeah so this uh
that's when we kind of started realizing
that hey this is uh
this is picking up a lot of steam now
very cool that's great to hear
um one of the benefits of running an
open source project that's successful is
you you start to get these
contributions full requests new features
also sort of
examples of of you know essentially
customers not paying customers but open
source customers are using the tool in
different configurations so i'm sure
harnessing the power of all that
feedback is very useful to the future
direction of the product
yeah definitely yes
yeah that's exciting um so well thanks
for sort of catching us up on on some of
the growth of the community um i also
wanted to ask you
um how has pino adopted or adapted i
should say to
um current trends in in the data world
um i know that you've made some other
improvements to pinot and i'm curious to
hear about them as well
uh yes uh this
this is a great question so
uh so one of the trends that
we were seeing as we were working on
pinot last few years is the shift from
highly structured data to
semi-structured or unstructured data
[Music]
and
like a few years ago it was so the data
set manager is also kind of one of the
tools that's
uh
helping with those trends but even
natively in pino there's
some like several features that we did
to make this uh easier
uh for example we've added a lot of uh
transformations that can happen on the
fly during ingestion
uh and this kind of further helps remove
the need for external systems where you
have to do pre-processing workflows for
common scenarios such as filtering or
adding derived columns or just
flattening your uh nested fields
so we added like a lot of um
transform functions in pino natively for
doing just basic uh
column manipulations and then we also
have a way to write uh groovy scripts
for like a very custom transform logic
and uh to go back to the plugability
point it's very easy for you to just add
your own transform function
as a udf annotate it with one
pre-decided
keyword and then just drop it in
your deployment and you will just be
able to use it
and that becomes its own its own column
then
yes so this it becomes its own udf and
then you can use that in your uh when
you're setting up your table to say that
hey this column is going to use this udl
get this whole new value
and then the other cool thing to
help with this whole semi-structured
unstructured uh
shift
was
that we
are now natively able to just ingest
say nested json or arbitrary complex
json or just complex data structures
and once it is in pino
we have added this cool index called
json index
that lets you so it's going to go and
index every field in your complex
arbitrary block no matter what it is
and you will be able to
reap the same low latency query
performance of your complex json blob as
if it were a column that was
thought off and pre-processed and uh
put something that you would have put a
proper index on so you can just say hey
here's my json column i'm setting a json
index on it and you're good to go
wow
that sounds like black magic
yeah some of our benchmarks have shown
some amazing improvement when we use a
json index on a column versus just
having to
read it and then parse it and then do
some manipulation to extract something
so almost like going from tens of
seconds to a few milliseconds because of
adding json index
that's that's super interesting um well
on the index point because i wanted to
ask you about this i've noticed that
pinot supports so many different kinds
of indexes on
on columns which is like amazing um can
you talk about some of the most popular
ones
uh yes
so
on the same lines as json index in the
to help with this semi-structured
unstructured data we also have or text
index
this is
so you can just in add a text index on
say a very large text blob
and then you can do phrase prefix regex
based text search queries
and then we have geospatial indexes so
if you have
coordinates then you can just use
natively or geospatial index to run
geospatial queries uh this was actually
a great contribution by uh uber folks
again and
they built one very interesting feature
called orders near you in uber reads
okay
that uses this index
behind the scenes so when you kind of
open your uber app
you'll see in real time the orders that
are happening near you wow
so
all in real time like so you can eat you
can eat what your neighbor's eating yeah
and you can see what's popular in the
area which restaurant
is
which restaurant has the most orders
today and they have something special
got it yeah
uh so these three kind of help a lot
with just uh
log analytics text search or building
special dashboards and
that are special dashboards for
personalization or user facing analytics
like ubereats example
some of the other cool indexes would be
uh so we
started off with the forward index
inverted index the sorted index the very
basic ones
then we added range indexes which are
for
range queries so typically if you have
something like greater than this time
less than this time
then this index will uh make it much
faster than using a traditional inverted
index or a sorted index
and then
we also have the star tree index
which is uh
of course how the company star tree gets
its name from
and uh this one is a very cool index
uh so
this one is kind of going to help you so
think of this extreme to use two ends of
a spectrum where you have your data
and you could either choose to
not pre-aggregate anything at all just
keep everything unpre-aggregated and
then when you get a query that is when
you will go and do the
roll-ups
and then the aggregate it and then
compute your result when you get the
query
this is of course sometimes going to be
very slow especially if you have like a
lot of point lookup queries um
then you probably don't want to be in
that
side of the spectrum when you want to do
low latency user facing analytics
and then you have the other end of the
spectrum where you have
you can just pre-compute everything
this is typically what key value stores
do which is pre-computed
keep the result ready for every possible
combination
but then there's two problems with this
you've lost
flexibility
because every time there's a new
dimension or there's some new data you
have to make sure that it's pre-computed
otherwise you're not going to be able to
use that
and then also just be computing
everything is
going to result in space explosion
so star tree index is the solution to
this
because it lets you pick exactly which
columns matter to you and pre-aggregate
only those
pick exactly which aggregation functions
matter to you
and compute only those so you could say
that oh in my data set only the
dimensions country browser and device
these are the ones that i will do point
lookup queries on
so i'm only going to pre-aggregate these
i only care about some of this metrics
say sum of impressions
uh and then you can also specify that
at any point i want to make sure that
the query doesn't have to
pre do aggregations on more than say 10
000 records
okay so with this you are exactly able
to control
the amount of time that it's going to
spend in pre-computation versus what's
already there
and then you can choose to be wherever
you want on the spectrum of
no pre-computations to pre-compute
everything and then choose it based on
your space and latency trade-off
requirements very interesting and
where's the predicate handled in the
star tree index
uh
so
so think of it as uh if you have say in
the example that we did uh country
browser device
so we're going to start with like the
star node and then let's say we uh do
pre computations for like a few
countries and then we see that there's
only 10 000 records left so you might
start with u.s and canada
india china and then you know that oh
now this is my uh star note so
i got it
then you go next so you have like kind
of country so if you have a query like
uh select something from uh us
a country equal to us then it's going to
traverse the tree
uh it will say
oh in u.s and now i'm going to see the
next browser so and so or if you don't
have browser column then you'll go to
the star node under us and then pick the
uh
columns under those so all right and
then pre-compute those pre-compute those
those values those those aggregations
yes exactly
got it
um yeah it sounds super super powerful
and i've seen it i've seen the the
benchmarks on some of those queries and
they're very
very fast especially i'm sure when
they're tuned well
cool um well i know there's a couple
other
features that you've
introduced do you want to talk to us
about
and
um joint support and a couple other key
things
oh yes definitely so
upsets was one of the most impressive
features added to pino in the recent few
years so this feature is where when you
get an event
you insert it if it doesn't exist update
it if it does exist
so this was spearheaded by another
interesting use case that uber
engineering was trying to solve and this
clearly stretched the boundaries of what
pino can do
so the use case they were trying to
solve was something like
a fair update that happens after a trip
is over so you maybe add a tip or some
toll gets added so your fare is now
different
or let's say in
retail i've seen the use case where
there's this order and the state of the
order keeps changing
so you're going to get new events but
but while for some applications you
might just be concerned with the latest
event or the latest date
or you might have some special logic
that if i have several events with this
primary key i want to do something and
compute like a better value for it and
not just go with all the values
so
this was basically the upset feature and
because of this pinot has now uh
shifted from immutable data store to
supporting mutability
and
this is like a game changer for olap
systems uh which so far used to be
mutable or sorry so far used to be
immutable
so we're seeing many people in the
community doing very interesting things
with this feature
awesome
um and what about joins i think you've
made some change some changes to the
join um the the query uh engine uh on
the joint side
yes uh so in fact just today we have
published a blog about uh
joins in apache pino
yes this is a very recent feature it's
still in an early release branch
so
i mean i remember two years ago when
kishore came on uh
data council thursday as well
uh i remember him mentioning that we've
consciously stayed away from joints so
far
it's like a
design choice
this is kind of uh
we don't want to do this for low latency
queries and we have like a presto
connector ecosystem with which we can uh
so you can do the joins if you have
presto and then kind of
and then uh
we keep kept hearing from users that hey
we really love you know and we want it
to be the single store
uh
and also just having everything natively
in uh pinot is
uh nice
and uh
it it's
uh so kind of these two reasons
motivated us to get to adding joint
support and uh
this
we had to make some interesting changes
to the architecture of pinot to support
this
so
earlier on when i explained the broker
layer and the server layer it was pretty
much the single stage scattergather for
the longest time that's how it used to
be
and this is fine for analytical queries
like say filter and then aggregate and
then
when you send everything back to the
broker it has to do like limited merging
of results
but then when you get to multi-stage
queries like joins or this poses some
limitations because
data sets often won't be co-located so
after like initial filtering on all the
servers if you send everything back to
the brokers directly before any
aggregations
you might have to do some data shuffling
and then some local join and then
another final aggregation
and
a single stage
merge phase is going to easily become
like this bottleneck
so to
support this we have added a multi-stage
query execution support
and
there's like a lot more details about
how this is done uh in the blog that was
published today
and the cool thing is this not only
unlocks joins but also gives us the
ability to
add other complex multi-stage operations
like say window functions
so yeah this is this is one of the new
upcoming features that we are very
excited about that's a big update for
sure um
we'll make sure and share that blog post
our community and
and get it out via social um so that
people are aware of those changes but
that sounds especially significant
congrats
on that
great
well um uh neha it's been it's been so
great chatting with you um
we're out of time but i wanted to ask
you where can the community reach out to
you and find you if they have other
questions about pinot
uh so definitely the pinot slag channel
uh
that's the fastest and easiest way to
find me
uh
and also
you can find me on twitter at
nehapavar18
um sounds great well thanks for joining
us neha it was great to chat with you
and and hear about your enthusiasm and
and all of your commits uh on the pinot
project
same year it was great chatting with you
pete thank you awesome
and to our listeners thanks for joining
um we'll have more dc thursdays coming
up
and don't forget that you can check out
all of our dc thursday previous
conversations on our playlist on youtube
you can also see all the all the talks
from our recent data council austin on
our youtube channel as well
so
stay tuned